l'idole des jeunes c'est lui si vous
avez plus de 20 ans et que vous ne
connaissez pas normal vous n'êtes pas
exactement le cœur de cible mais si vous
êtes en âge d'avoir des enfants en
primaire ou au collège difficile de
passer à côté du phénomène d'abord avec
son groupe section d'assaut puis en
solo pas trop que c'était lui en fait je
je je produis sans trop cibler mais une
fois que le morceau il est produit je
sais à qui ça va parler en l'écoutant
tout ça
à la fin de madame je savais ça allait
parler plus à la jeunesse
que
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vieux madame PAV un titre qui parle au
jeunes évidemment et qui pourrait
inquiéter les parents puisquon fait pas
vraiment l'apologie de la réussite
scolaire et en même temps qui n'a pas un
jour rêvé de régler son compte à la
surveillante générale mais au fait
a-telle vraiment existé madame
PAV
coner d'orientation que j'ai pu avoir
j'ai fait un cocktail de toutes ces
dames et je me suis inventé un nom dans
ma tête ça a donné madame pavoch et
voilà j'en ai fait un morceau second
degré que tout le monde connaît
[Musique]
aujourd'huice que vous aim chez Black sa
voixante bien son son il est frais appte
de la bonne humeur et tout et c'est
[Musique]
jeune comme dans les années 60 on
pouvait être plutôt Beatles ou Rolling
Stones voir chat sauvage ou chaussette
noire dans le même genre on peut aussi
préférer soprano l'autre star de la
soirée rap avec son tube le
clown grâce à eux le W la plus grande
salle du praton 6500 spectateurs ich
complet à l'avance pour la seule fois de
la
semaine